okay the next game
and uh actually one of my
favorite opponents international master
from latvia i think and
um
he's um something of
yeah my worst nightmare on icc because
i have a score like i'm not sure
i'm sure four points out of 40 or
something
it's really ridiculous
but um he's a strong player
very quick and
it doesn't make many mistakes okay
got a catalan opening
i'm not sure if i'm somehow confused
mousse already
okay it still looks fairly healthy
it's a rather typical end game for the
catalan
bishop e3 maybe
d7 is hanging now
i don't mind to have the knight with the
bishop because
the knight always has got chances to
get some play against them on slightly
weakened pawns
the problem against this guy is that he
basically
um doesn't make any mistakes in the end
game
so you need to kill him
more than once so to say check
a better end game usually doesn't mean
much
this is a better end game
okay so keep it simple
maybe i should play for more here but
it's just that my score against him is
so ridiculously bad
i'm always content with
very dry position
where i can make a draw it's just that
simple
the thing is you might also
play this on time
draw offer i try to offer a draw of it
he will play this on time
check
check
check
check
okay no no time drama
sorry yeah of course this was a really
boring game but
you have to understand that i out of 40
games i won
i won exactly one game and i lost
35 or something so i'm pretty content
with
stupid games like this